foreign
[Music]
people on the planet things can feel
pretty crowded
let's make things a bit tighter by
housing every single person on Earth in
one giant skyscraper
but a building big enough for 8 billion
of us doesn't exist yet
oh we're gonna have to build one from
the ground up
but before we do let's start small and
work our way up with one that could hold
at least a country or two
we'll start with some of the least
populated countries and move on to the
most gigantic skyscraper Earth has ever
seen
could it reach the Moon
when we talk about cramming everyone on
earth into the same space equality is
one of the top issues we'd face you know
in the real world we say things to
low-income people like pull yourself up
by your bootstraps but that phrase
denies the reality of the working class
or very often the Working Poor
look sometimes we all need a hand
especially when you're already pushing
yourself to the Limit and you shouldn't
feel ashamed for accepting the help you
need
government programs like the child tax
credit go a long way toward reducing the
stigma of receiving support from social
programs because they work and they keep
our children fed the child tax credit of
2021 kept nearly 2.9 Million children
out of poverty by giving nearly thirty
six hundred dollars per child to Working
Families and if you want to extend this
legislation to 2023 there's a small
window between midterm elections and
winter recess to get it done
we have the chance to make sure our
neighbors and communities don't go
without
because just like in this skyscraper
we're all stuck here together
for this experiment you'd be housing 10
000 people on each floor and that would
make your Iceland building almost half
as tall as the Eiffel Tower in Paris
that's not as exciting as some of our
next skyscrapers are about to get
and it would only take you just over two
minutes to get to its top floor which
would be floor 34.
still it would be good practice for you
to figure out the infrastructure to
support all your residents
[Music]
next on the list the Australia
skyscraper
now this is where things get interesting
because at 10 kilometers high this
building would be taller than Mount
Everest and to commute all the way to
the top of your Australia skyscraper
you'd need to spend two hours and 40
minutes one way
but that's nothing compared to our next
engineering feat
[Music]
to shelter every resident of the United
Kingdom you need to think bigger than
Big Ben's height
like almost 300 times bigger your United
Kingdom skyscraper would have a whopping
6 800 floors
it would reach a height of 27 kilometers
and after floor 4 500 you'd now be above
the clouds
[Music]
Philippines is home to over 100 million
people and to house all of them your
skyscraper would need to be 40
kilometers high
this man-made monolith would have ten
thousand floors and most of it would be
above the clouds
it would take you 11 hours to get to the
top floor of the Philippine skyscraper
so hopefully you don't have to come down
all that often
[Music]
moving on up to something a little
taller your Mexico building would be a
jaw-dropping 52 kilometers high
that's twice as tall as the tallest
mountain in the solar system Olympus
Mons on Mars
it would take you 14 and a half hours to
travel all the way up to its 13
000 floor
once there you're halfway to outer space
but at least you'd still have the
atmosphere around you I can't say that
about your next Mega structure
[Laughter]
the United States skyscraper would be
really really tall reaching a height of
132 kilometers and after floor 25
000 you'd officially be in space
pretty cool huh but only if you don't
think about the wild temperatures just
outside your window
the top of this building would be in the
thermosphere and contrary to what you
might think this layer is incredibly hot
rising to 2500 degrees Celsius
but if you were to open a window you'd
feel cold
that's because in this layer of our
atmosphere there aren't enough air
molecules to transfer that heat to you
oh and that would also make breathing
impossible so you'd really need to focus
on installing a proper oxygen support
system
you know for the bent house tenants to
survive
[Music]
okay on to one of the most populated
countries in the world
the India skyscraper would be
unimaginably tall
reaching a height of
552 kilometers that's 138
000 floors
and to get to the top you should expect
a travel time in excess of six days
if I lived way up there I don't think
I'd ever go down
the India skyscraper would be taller
than the orbit of satellites and even
the International Space Station
now that you'd be in space you'd really
need to build proper oxygen water and
Waste Systems you have to think about
how to feed all those people because
transporting food from the ground would
be virtually impossible
and now to the tallest skyscraper of all
time
the super mega structure that would hold
all 8 billion of us
the Earth Tower
[Music]
the Earth Tower might not reach the moon
but it would be almost as tall as the
moon's diameter this incredible
structure would have 800
000 floors and it would peek at a
mind-boggling
3200 kilometers
depending on where you'd live here you'd
see planes satellites and the ISS
it's somewhat ironic that most of the
earth Tower would be in space well above
our planet's atmosphere
forget about a balcony with a view of
the Moon
you wouldn't want to go outside unless
you were wearing a spacesuit
okay now let's talk about trying to
piece the tower together
in addition to its own weight it would
need to support the weight of the entire
global population
at about
356 million tons
this would already be nearly 1 000 times
heavier than the Empire State Building
to provide everyone with clean water add
to that the equivalent of four and a
half million Olympic-sized swimming
pools that would be consumed every day
and I'm not even talking about food or
other essential stuff here
the lower floors of this megastructure
would be dark and gloomy there'd likely
be high crime rates as people did
whatever it takes to survive
the top floors would belong to the rich
they'd be dependent upon the work of
these lower levels
life would be complicated in our giant
new skyscraper infectious diseases could
spread at never before seen speeds
overcrowding would lead to widespread
mental health issues
but at least you'd have an incredible
amount of room to enjoy Outdoors on the
ground level with everyone in one
building
only your elevator commute from the very
top floor to the bottom would take you
about 37 days
maybe things could be worse than living
way up high in the sky
like what if every single person lived
Underground
well that's a story
for another
[Music]